within three seconds of that happening
my phone was exploding in my pocket it's
go check you know that voice you got
Steven yeah yeah this is the sign of the
end and the birth of a new blood King I
[Music]
don't want to do the show I don't want
to do it let's do it let's go say where
we are
that's where but that wasn't the biggest
news the biggest news the weekend was
about referees I'm not talking about
Sarah Thomas is the first female in the
playoffs we're talking about this moment
348 in the fourth quarter
Patrick mahomes is gonna take this snap
you were focused on Tyree it was I was
total fanboy right here and then all of
a sudden you're in another Stratus man
oh my god look at that balance in the
pocket oh and on the back foot dude this
is the first time you've danced well in
your life how dare you say that left
uh-oh nature huh oh my god thank you
graphics department that whatever if you
like to be a me Ike I mean I don't even
know what to say all I could say is
literally right there I was becoming a
fanboy I was off the white but of course
it's my fault I should have been farther
off the white and I've been on sidelines
like my whole life and that's never had
never been hit by a memory or like a
coach forever never and I was I'm not
gonna do it cuz it looked like you were
angry did you apologize I was literally
apologizing as I was skipping backwards
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
literally did that and then you know I
continued to apologize and then I went
into the next play and I he did he go oh
don't worry about it it's totally
totally not he was pissed off and how
many curses he know so then yeah I think
he might have said like get the F out of
the way right and then the next play I'm
continuing to apologize and I go man I'm
really sorry I'm a dumbass and he looked
at I mean he goes at least you know it
and then he lined over and went back to
business but other graphs on the field
knew it was me and they were like
chuckling that's such a good burn dance
so I knew I was in trouble left go cuz I
swear to you within three seconds of
that happening
my phone was exploding in my pocket now
it's probably my pants everybody saw it
yeah it was amazing one of my favorite
moments in divisional playoff history
yeah well you know what else is amazing
oh there was a game at 4:40 on Sunday
that was quite enjoyable
I missed it I was repotting mr. drew
brees hater right here how do you how
many guards do you throw more in the end
eight hundred no way I'll answer for you
okay here's the first one so I want to
say something I have not looked at my
mentions yeah since the game I've
avoided them completely so I only
imagine what people were saying all
right well this is an intelligent one
because this is Ted MD Oh doctor oh yes
he's a doctor
and he wrote love it you talking filly
rat haha that's perfect way to go Ted MD
they decode that phrase yes you talking
filly right
I felt that through the screen yeah
you're right that one that was that was
hard-hitting right okay the doctor
here's another creative name Fifty
Shades of Bray okay I like this I
scribed this with exuberance as I've
been salivating all week long to tweet
you about the most overrated quarterback
in NFL history your allegiance to pick
foals Ezell certainly skewed your
analytical prowess suck it die Eagles
die the best part is is that he totally
went to thesaurus.com and yes up
exuberance but then ended it with suck
it yeah because really the first two
sentences were good and then it equals
suck yeah that was pretty good
way to go Thanks Braley and then we got
old tweet number three with just
yup mirrors what the hell's his name
again mr. beam mr. beam right yes mr.
beam going by going hey Adam let's go my
name is Drew Brees and eat that I'm just
gonna be honest yeah we're having our
Sims and Lefko show down in Atlanta's at
Dan Tana's email Sims and left Co at
gmail.com if you'd like to be there
Thursday at 6 o'clock Saints fans are
worried about ya I need the real Sims
and left go fans to get in there because
I'm just worried it's gonna be a bunch
of mr. Bean's that are Saints fans yeah
I'm tired yeah you might have that sorry
I'm really nervous
yeah that's alright hey it was a good
season though no joke Philly the Eagles
yes but what they joke no joke I'm not
even messing around a Super Bowl team to
basically fall off the earth midway
through the year and usually when a
Super Bowl team falls off like that they
go uh okay we won the Super Bowl last
year we'll see you next year yeah the
rally back really become again one of
the better teams in football have a
chance to win that game so props ear he
goes I'll give you that much you just
witness one of the first genuine moments
in Sims and left goes all right let's go
Jamal Adams and I'm on Sims and left oh
not two guys all right we have Steven
Jackson we don't waste any more time
just go all right so here we go you got
two teams you played two out of the four
teams you Rams the Patriots we'll get to
the Patriots in a second but first of
all do you root for the Rams like are
you a Rams fan because of your time
there that's a no that was a
that was body language it is bad I know
you're one of the all-time greats and
Rams history it's you Dickerson and
girly and Faulk what's the weight like
that's where I want to go right because
he's gonna ask my question now too is do
you alright so first of all do you root
for the Rams just fit start I do but I
it's bittersweet right yeah it's like
you give them almost a decade nine years
you give them everything you have never
better than eight and eight right nine
seasons I had six coaches right County
and or interim coach yeah yeah so all I
know it's turnover yeah and now to see
the success of this one for you is the
greatest show on turf yeah after you is
Sean McVeigh this off explosion in
between
yeah I'm just to meet ya so I do I mean
you're one of the great running backs of
all time your 18th on the all-time
rushing list wild do you feel like
you're almost like the forgotten man not
only as a whole but for the Rams like I
feel like people just go Marshall Faulk
and Todd Gurley and they forget that you
were like a super stud in the NFL for a
long time yeah but what my favorite
questions the fans did say that rock
fans is who's the leading rusher for
them the LA Rams right most people say
Eric Dickerson is like well you don't
know your history you didn't watch me oh
yeah alright and I that's the
frustrating part is you know understand
that team leadership and team wins come
together and I just wasn't a part of
that team yeah but when you talk about
individual and what a person put out on
the field what we worked hard to do yeah
I just want some acknowledgement and
right time I feel like I'll get skipped
over and it's not because of my talent I
know that it's just because I just had a
bad break yeah yeah it's everyone says
that wins isn't a statistic but yet we
treat it like it's the greatest
statistic of all you're right yeah
that's kind of how it goes but what's
funny is is then you go to the Patriots
which there's nothing better than Bill
Belichick with a guy that hasn't been
getting respect from another team having
with Corey Dillon it happened with like
every safety wide-receivers Apple Chad
Johnson our friend you go there what was
your first meeting with Belichick like
what were your what was a great
Belichick story about who he really is
my story Belichick is he calls me in
December LeGarrette Blount goes down hmm
that was the holidays or he
down and I'm retired at this point in my
head and it's Belichick you know the
voice it's very distinct and he goes
Stephen yeah yeah he go Stephen I got it
I got a question for you do you want to
play football again and I'm like in my
head like of course I do
yeah but am i during December listen New
England Patriots and I'm a man of pride
I don't want to look bad like alas my
last carry I felt I still look like
myself I didn't want to get to New
England and look like a shell of myself
yeah and they're people that all he's
you know he's terrible he's trash so I
was more nervous about public opinion
about what I would look like so I said
coach he's given me two weeks to get in
shape
I'll come what was it like going there
seeing their day-to-day preparation and
specifically like the AFC Championship
getting ready for the Broncos that year
what that was like being a part of that
organization during that time so will
you get there you realize that there's
no place like in the NFL which lasts my
stops yeah there's not a lot of pictures
in the in the hallways there's not a lot
of mimimi
you know but well I found the most
interesting to your question is getting
ready for the AFC game against the
Denver Broncos if I recall right he
asked me to talk to the team and he
wanted me to talk to them about my NFL
experience I'm like what do I have to
teach these guys you know you guys been
to now eight consecutive AFC
championship right groan Kowski laugh he
goes I've never had not a bye
yeah oh my god I want to be the player
twice first year in the last year yeah
he's the Laughing like you got a bad
break so he asked me to talk about my
plight sometimes the team about my story
and my story goes there's a there's a
part of my career where I won six games
in three years Wow
I'm talking to the team about me winning
six games in three years yeah and you
could just hear a pin drop and they just
couldn't believe the amount of eight
consecutive thousand yards rushing but
the lack of the wins to go with it it's
almost like those guys wanting to win
that game for me
yeah and that was a special moment
because I didn't think my story wasn't
anything I thought I was just a
privilege to be there but that it was
two folds and that they wanted me to
kind of cap off my career or with the
win it meant a lot to me and I know I'll
always forever be granting you got a
touchdown in the AFC Championship game
Denver I think he was trying to like
like you know Belichick like is he
trying to show like hey you guys are
spoiled and not a kind of grateful this
up yeah okay you can't take it for
granted right and I think if you're grim
Kowski for example yeah he doesn't know
anything else yeah yeah he holding those
brady Belichick and playoff wins
Cincinnati's like that yeah yeah yeah
now they're in a similar situation they
haven't been in that situation since
your speech in that game of a road AFC
championship game and since 2004 they've
been in the playoffs like 13 times this
is only happen three times and the
Patriots are Owen three went through in
the room I'm curious what is Pella check
like the week of an AFC championship
game
very relaxed everybody and I would say
the whole team that's the dab with the
other thing that's impressive
from the running back coach to the
special teams coach to even just the
team chaplain nothing it is nothing's
different there it is normal football in
January February is normal to them it's
the regular City sounds like you were in
a bizarro world
we were like I've never been here before
this is insane everyone's like it's
Tuesday Stephen take a seat yeah I'm
normally looking at my passport I mean
close to Rick until the vision or a week
my only other thing is if you could say
anything to the basketball Stephen
Jackson yeah what would you say to him
stack five with uh-huh do you guys like
talk to the Stephen Jackson's talk to
each other no we haven't talked in a
while we ran into each other before
coincidence
highly enough it was in a nightclub in
San Antonio and I we got each other's
bills did you you don't want to mess
that NBA there's been some mix-up
that's all I love it we're happy to have
you man thank you Mary yeah thanks for
coming real seriously how I'm LaMarr
Woodley and you're watching ceilings and
left go let's go left go let's go are to
say let's go
what do you know left goes locks have
been hitting in the playoffs I haven't
needed anybody let alone somebody 7 and
1 and for the season I'm 34 34 and three
oh five hundred feels good no thanks to
Ally
he's Owen - in the playoffs and you know
I'm letting him hear about it
this man is Owen - in the playoffs he's
gone from Ally the Oracle to Ally the
mush and I'm seven and one against the
spread in the playoffs Ally I'm open for
advice if you need it your team is out
of it though so what evident one it
means a lot to lightly go chiefs are
favored by three at home against the
Patriots Chiefs Patriots I don't have a
pick I need some I need some help with
this one timeout
I need a universe a little bit out for a
little of co guidance because it would
be my pleasure little bit I'm leanin
Chiefs okay but it's tough to me to go
against Tom Brady what do you think my
thing is is that Tom doesn't have to
play in the championship games on the
road often he's only had three road
games since 2004 Broncos Steelers Colts
I believe and he's lost all three of
them I would go Chiefs because I think
it's the it's Patrick mahomes at home I
don't know I love that kid I feel the
magic patching the homes at home
Arrowhead I had the first game was in
Foxborough yes geez you see that you got
his eyes got a white Walker the chains
she's alright we're gonna let you know
that oh if Tom Brady wins New England
with Super Bowl you didn't have to come
then you know now Wow I felt Oracle
emanation right there that was really
serious sounds crazy I'm going against
him this week but if they win I'm going
with him in a Super Bowl
typical Ally hedging right don't worry
we'll be fine
so Ally finally comes to his senses
listens to what I have to say and he's
taking the Chiefs - three ok gonna be
honest threes a lot of points I'm gonna
wait until Patriots betters knock it
down and then I'm gonna bet on the
Chiefs
yeah I hear that but you think the
Chiefs are gonna win I do think the
Chiefs are gonna win I mean all both of
these games should be really cause so
Dino against the page but III do if you
made me bet on this game I would take
the Chiefs maybe to win a
four point game 34 30 35 31 something
like that see high-scoring yes somewhere
rematches of our amazing regular-season
games in those two games over a hundred
and sixty points scored but I don't
think it's gonna be the same game and I
know that you definitely don't know
so Saints ran yes what's gonna be
different about that game for the first
match well I think the first thing that
jumps out to me is one stat line with
Michael Thomas 12 receptions 211 yards
right had the unbelievable performance
burned Marcus Peters and one of the
biggest plays of the game Sean Payton
said they like the matchup we're gonna
see that little rivalry flame you know
didn't play in that Killeen to leave did
not play and the other big point left go
is this that the the Rams don't play
those style of defenses anymore they are
not really a matchup man-to-man defense
like they were back in week 11 now they
have really become more of a zone team
we're gonna play sound coverages in the
back end that our front for get after
the quarterback or so hey Michael Thomas
he's extremely hard to defend we know
that not only because he's a good player
yeah but Sean Payton moves him around
everywhere you know what I think he
could be around a hundred yards yeah but
no way around 200 years I was also the
Sheldon rankin's breakout gay it was he
won't bite out there right that's big -
crazy sad about that game no sacks right
can you believe that
that's insane no I would not say that
what happened in Chiefs Patriots during
the regular season that's definitely not
happening on Sunday I think the big
thing to look at there is there's 13
total rush attempts by the Kansas City
Chiefs running backs and that football
game Andy Reid man yes that's Andy Reid
we know that so what why I say that
won't happen again the first reason is
this the Chiefs have been trying to be a
more balanced team we saw that last week
against the Colts Damien Williams had
some success running between the tackles
so I think they've been underneath the
center with Patrick mahomes the attempts
are very important because when you
become one-dimensional against Bill
Belichick and company you're in deep
trouble if they can just go oh you're
gonna throw the ball every down they're
gonna come up with a million different
coverages to confuse mahomes doubles
blitzes everything under the moon okay
so the big thing there would be the
attempts because it keeps the Patriots
defense honest and then with mahomes
under center one of the great things
about being under
Center and running the ball is the
play-action passes and we've seen that a
little more from them as of late to to
get Tyreke down the field
Kelsey down the field but can Andy redo
it will he stay with it because you know
as an Eagles fan
he loves to throw the ball but when they
played in the Superbowl Patriots Eagles
he threw the ball 50 plus something
times yes he does that again they're in
trouble
or if they rush the ball for 13 attempts
or less that means they got down early
and had a throw and they're in trouble
anyways mm that would be my two cents
your analysis is fine oh thanks but
something is happening Sunday night that
scares me and I don't know what it means
yet yeah apparently it's gonna happen
during the cheese Patriots game right
over Arrowhead yeah
a super Blood Wolf Moon and with the
arctic blast is happening during the
game yes I don't know if this is going
to be Belichick using the universe to
suck the powers out of Patrick mahomes
and give it in to Brady for another 20
years of his career or if this is the
sign of the end and the birth of a new
blood King in Patrick mahomes to reign
over the NFL and we are all powerless to
his majesty I mean red moon over Kansas
City would mean I would think powers to
Kansas City your analysis was fine there
as well thanks but a saying if you see
Belichick start itching his neck and
start crawling on all fours run because
it could get dicey for sense peace out
homey and the lef koe man we will holla
holla holla at you later
enjoy the super Red Bull Wolf Moon
vampire what just enjoy the game
[Music]
before we start yeah that's a corn
Berkeley spice
yes that's what it's like oh they're
unreal right that's like Jamal Anderson
alright
it is the running back running back yeah
you just don't see that kind yeah yeah
it's a fire hydrant yeah hey what's up
homies thanks for watching subscribe to
the be our YouTube channel man you're
such a millennial also while you're here
we have a lot other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square
he ruined it it was really close